a bit of breaking news we've got for you
the uk government has apparently uh
opened an official investigation
into david cameron's lobbying uh let's
bring in our political correspondent joe
pike you can tell us more
uh joe what are they saying well some
white hall sources in the last few
minutes jane have confirmed an
independent review will begin shortly we
don't know
any of the details yet who will chair
that review who will lead the review
and indeed what will it look into is it
just the most
recent allegations that mr cameron has
been lobbying
the current government or is it about
the access that
lex greensill got to david cameron's
administration having this extraordinary
access
to senior officials and getting a
business out of it as well i'm sure as
the day progresses
we will have more details for you but it
certainly
i think is a pretty worrying time for mr
cameron he's likely to be
questioned as our officials and
ministers
in the uh current government and we
should really point out it has been the
work of journalists
at the sunday times and financial times
over the last three weeks
have really uncovered the full pretty
uh jaw-dropping details of not just mr
cameron's lobbying but the access mr
green still had
to his government so whitehall sources
jane confirming the last few minutes
there will be an
independent inquiry into the cameron
green sill affair
but we'll have to wait until later in
the day for the full details